mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait ça fait déjà
un bout de temps que le manuscrit d'insi
par les aratustra a été remis à
l'imprimeur et le manuscrit n'est
toujours pas en vente Nietzsche qui a
environ 40 ans s'impatiente et ne
comprend pas et qu'est-ce qu'il apprend
en fait l'imprimeur a volontairement
laissé de côté le manuscrit il veut
d'abord satisfaire une commande urgente
de 500000 recueils de cantique qui
doivent être livrés à temps pour PAC
bien sûr Nietzsche est énervé mais il
trouve aussi la situation comique lui
que certains appellent l'Antéchrist
l'auteur de la formule dieu est mort se
fait passer devant par une compilation
de champs religieux une trentaine
d'années plus tard c'est la première
guerre mondiale pour soutenir les
valeurs des soldats allemands le haut
commandement militaire leur fait
distribuer le Nouveau Testament mais ce
n'est pas le seul livre que les soldats
reçoivent ils reçoivent également ainsi
par les arathustra de Nietzsche l'armée
allemande a fait imprimer 150000
[Musique]
exemplaires ce qui s'est passé avec
Nietzsche est inédit dans l'histoire de
la pensée moderne sa philosophie est
rejetée pendant toute sa vie puis elle
connaît un décollage dans ses 10
dernières années et enfin après sa mort
en 1900 sa philosophie devient purement
et simplement une des plus influentes du
20e siècle Nietzsche est aujourd'hui le
philosophe moderne le plus populaire sa
tête avec sa moustache et ses lunettes
est une image familière presque un
symbole de la pensée comment expliquer
que des livres qui pourrissaient dans
les entrepôts du vivant de l'auteur
soitent aujourd'hui de perpétuels
bestseller et même bien plus que ça des
chef-dœuvres et des symboles de la
civilisation occidentale la réponse à
cette question est dans la vie de
Nietzsche écoutez-moi jusqu'au bout et
vous comprendrait pourquoi et comment
s'est produit le plus grand comeback de
la philosophie
moderne quand Ludwick Nietzsche se met à
jouer du piano son tout jeune fils
Friedrich laisse tomber ce avec quoi il
est en train de jouer et écoute avec une
attention captivée son père est le seul
dans le village à extraire de si beaux
sons de l'instrument ça le place
au-dessus des simples mortels pour le
jeune Friedrich c'est déjà comme ça par
son talent de pianiste que Ludwig nietzs
avait séduit la famille de sa femme la
mère du futur philosophe et ce n'est pas
son se seul talent en tant que
précepteur Ludwick Nietzsche s'était
fait remarquer pour son savoir il savait
le latin le grec et se débrouillit en
français il faut dire qu'il était
lui-même le fils d'un pasteur
intellectuellement talentueux le
grand-père du philosophe donc après
avoir été précepteur dans des familles
princières pendant 7 ans Ludwick le père
du philosophe devient pasteur à son tour
pour une communauté regroupant trois
villages près de leiptish ce que montre
cette anecdote c'est que le talent de
Nietzsche ne vient pas de nulle part il
hérite son talent musical de son père
comme lui il sera un pianiste accompli
mais surtout Nietzsche descend de deux
hommes de pasteurs son père et son
grand-père qui se distinguent par leur
supériorité intellectuelle si l'enfant
Nietzsche admire son paternel il n'en
reçoit pas une influence durable son
père meurt quand il a seulement 5 ans
mais il continue de grandir dans un
milieu où le savoir est valorisé sa mère
déménage pour se rapprocher de sa
famille les membres de cette famille qui
appartiennent à la bourgeoisie
intellectuelle il y a notamment des
avocats la famille maternelle supervise
l'éducation du jeune
Nietzsche nous sommes en septembre 1858
le destin du jeune qui a presque 14 ans
angoisse sa mère sa famille veut envoyer
son fils dans une école pour orphelin
mais elle refuse la chance lui sourit
les excellents résultats scolaires de
Nietzsche attire l'attention du recteur
du prestigieux internat de Pforta qui
accueille les meilleurs élèves de toute
l'Allemagne Nietzsche obtient une bourse
son avenir scolaire est assuré et pas
n'importe quel avenir scolaire 6 ans de
formation intellectuelle très intense
madame de style l'autrice française du
tournant du 19e siècle qui a lancé le
romantisme français à partir du
romantisme allemand madame de St a dit à
propos de la formation intellectuelle en
Allemagne ce que l'on appelle étude en
Allemagne est véritablement admirable 15
he par jour de solitude et de travail
pendant des années leur semblent un mode
de vie normal la mère de Nietzsche qui
est une fille de la campagne l'avait
habitué à se lever tôt vers 5h du matin
mais AB forta le lever commence à 4h du
matin peu après 5h du matin les élèves
doivent être assis dans leur salle
d'études et puis ils se mettent à faire
du latin du grec et de l'allemand
principalement avec un niveau d'exigence
qu'ils n'ont jamais connu Nietzsche est
un des est tout meilleur non seulement
il est intellectuellement doué et
travailleur mais il est aussi curieux il
ne se contente pas des œuvres programme
ce sont ses intenses années d'études à
forta qui donne t nietichzs le fond
culturel et intellectuel pour être un
grand penseur il en tire également comme
les élèves passés par la classe
préparatoire en France une discipline et
une capacité de travail supérieure dans
la quarantaine son mode de vie spariat
étonne encore les hôteliers il se lève
chaque matin avant l'aube pour se laver
à l'au froide avant d'abattre plusieurs
heures
[Musique]
d'écriture à 21 an Nietzsche étudie la
philologie c'est-à-dire l'étude critique
des textes anciens à l'université de
l'iptik le propriétaire de son logement
a une boutique de livre d'occasion un
jour que Nietzsche fouine dans cette
boutique il tombe sur le monde comme
volonté et comme représentation de
Schopenhauer il le feuillette d'abord
distraitement puis il commence à lire
captiver le style est tellement plus
lisible que celui de Kant ou egel et
puis il y a une familiarité dans le ton
qui fascine niet de retour chez lui il
se pose sur son canapé et se plonge dans
le monde comme volonté et comme
représentation comme beaucoup de gens
Nietzsche est transformé par cette
lecture sa vision du monde et de
l'existence s'écroule pendant plusieurs
semaines il s'abandonne à une orgie
d'autocritique en remplissant un journal
de pensée haineus contre lui-même il est
proche de la folie mais heureusement sa
discipline le sauve la découverte de
Schopenhauer est un tournant
intellectuel décisif et c'est également
le cas pour plusieurs des amis de
Nietzsche et plus généralement pour
beaucoup d'Allemands de sa génération
pour Nietzsche comme pour la plupart la
dépression liée à la découverte de la
vision du monde chopenhauerienne ne dure
que quelques semaines mais chopenhauer
devient ensuite une une sorte de
demi-dieu intellectuel pour le jeune
Nietzsche il dit que c'est le meilleur
philosophe des 1000 dernières années il
garde le monde comme volonté et comme
représentation et par herga et par
alipomena auprès de lui et il les
consulte comme une bible comment résumer
l'influence de Schopenhauer sur
Nietzsche tout d'abord Nietzsche se met
à voir le monde comme un ensemble
d'appétit conflictuel dépourvu de sens
ensuite il adopte le mépris de
Schopenhauer pour les profs et les
universitaires et enfin Schopenhauer lui
inspire le désir d'élaborer sa propre
philosophie originale c'est d'ailleurs
en élaborant sa propre pensée que nietzs
se détachera plus tard de Schopenhauer
et des fans de Schopenhauer mais ça
n'efface pas sa dette l'influence de
l'auteur du Monde comme volonté et comme
représentation a été décisive dans le
dessin de Nietzsche sans Schopenhauer
nous n'aurions pas eu
Nietzsche à 24 ans Nietzsche qui vient
de terminer ses études à leipzik est
invité à un dîner en comité restreint
autour de Richard Wagner Wagner qui a 55
ans est déjà un compositeur célèbre pour
ses opéras grandioses pour Nietzsche
c'est une rencontre incroyable il est
passionné de musique mais surtout il a
déjà acheté des partitions de Wagner il
les a étudié et il a été très
impressionné par le style du compositeur
bref il est fan et là il D avec le
maître lui-même comnich a une
connaissance approfondie de son travail
la séduction est réciproque mais il y a
autre chose à un moment de leur
discussion Wagner se met à lui parler de
Schopenhauer le seul philosophe selon
lui à avoir compris la véritable nature
de la musique Wagner dit à Nietzsche
qu'il doit beaucoup à Schopenhauer au
moment de se dire au revoir le
compositeur de 55 ans prend la main de
son admirateur de 24 ans la presse
chaudement et l'invite vite chez lui en
Suisse pour qu'il continue à parler de
Schopenhauer c'est le début d'une
profonde amitié elle sera déterminante
dans la vie et dans la pensée de
Nietzsche conquis par l'admiration
sincère et par le talent intellectuel de
son jeune admirateur Wagner en fait un
de ses plus proches fidèles presque un
membre de sa famille le compositeur est
un homme très charismatique il envoûte
Nietzsche et on peut également imaginer
que l'orphelin trouve en lui une figure
paternelle la femme de Wagner kozima
aime beaucoup Nietzsche elle aussi il
fera donc pas mal de voyages pour leur
rendre visite ou pour assister aux
représentations les plus prestigieuses
il leur enverrera ses textes et ses
essais il sollicitera leur avis Wagner
et Nietzsche partagent la conviction que
la musique a le pouvoir d'exprimer les
vérités les plus profondes de
l'existence humaine il s'influence
réciproquement la musique de Wagner
influence la pensée de Nietzsche c'est
notamment sensible dans la naissance de
la tragédie un des chefdœuvres du
philosophe et réciproquement la pensée
de Nietzsche aide Wagner à donner un
sens à sa musique le jeune intellectuel
contribue à étendre l'influence
culturelle du célèbre compositeur et le
célèbre compositeur lui fait bénéficier
de son entre gens après ce n'est pas un
échange conscient les deux me paraissent
sincères ils sont très proches pendant
environ une décennie mais à partir d'un
moment Nietzsche commence à résister à
l'influence de Wagner il s'écarte des
conceptions du maître il a ses propres
idées ça déplaitt à Wagner qui il faut
bien l'avouer a tendance à voir en
Nietzsche un relais intellectuel pour sa
propagande culturelle mais de son côté
Nietzsche joue aussi du prestige de
Wagner un de ses livres qui se vendra le
mieux sera d'ailleurs un panflet contre
le compositeur le cas
Wagner à la fin de la vingtaine
Nietzsche est prof de philologie à
l'université de ball les cours
accueillent en moyenne plusieurs
dizaines d'étudiants jusqu'à près de 60
pour les plus populaires pour le cours
de nietzs sur la rhétorique grec et
romaine seuls deux étudiants se sont
inscrits son cours sur Homer n'aura même
pas lieu Nietzsche se rend à l'évidence
il est un prof raté pourtant quelques
années plus tôt il était considéré comme
une future star de la philologie
allemande tant il avait été brillant
lors de ses études universitaires
l'université de bal l'avait donc voulu
pour le prestige de son département de
philologie elle lui a même accordé un
traitement de faveur il a été été nommé
professeur sans passer les examens ni
soumettre une thèse mais voilà quelques
années plus tard rien ne s'est passé
comme prévu c'est un peu comme les
jeunes prodiges que les plus grands club
de foot arrache à coup de million et qui
déçoivent les espoirs placés en eux
comment expliquer l'échec académique de
Nietzsche tout d'abord en déménageant à
bal il perd son cercle d'amis et la vie
culturelle de leipsik ensuite il se
désintéresse de la discipline dans
laquelle il excè et qu'il est censé
enseigner la philologie et le fait que
les étudiants désertent ses cours ne
l'encouragent pas assez rapidement il
ambitionne d'enseigner la philosophie il
demande à administration de le faire
changer de matière en vain il écrit
alors la naissance de la tragédie pour
faire avancer sa cause il se dit que si
ce livre marche bien ça lui donnera la
légitimité pour obtenir un poste de prof
de philo mais comme souvent dans la vie
l'effet n'est pas celui qu'on attend les
philologues les plus réputés lisent la
naissance de la tragédie et ils estiment
que c'est simplement du n'importe quoi
le livre détruit donc la réputation de
philologue de Nietzsche et ça rejaillit
sur la réputation de l'université elle
n'attire plus les étudiants de
philologie qui lui préfèrent désormais
ses concurrentes c'est un peu comme si
un jeune footballeur prodige marqué
contre son camp enfin il y a une
dernière raison et pas des moindres qui
explique l'échec académique de Nietzsche
pardon pour l'interruption mais j'ai une
question à vous poser vous croyez
vraiment que les gens ont lu tous les
livres dont ils parlent bien sûr que non
sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de
grand-chose et oui il y a 24 heures dans
une journée et il faut travailler manger
dormir et sortir le
chien donc le secret de la culture
générale ce n'est pas de lire des livres
c'est quoi alors en fait il n'y a pas un
un seul secret il y en a cinq les
étudiants et les personnes les plus
cultivées les profs et les intellectuels
connaissent ces cinq secrets vous savez
vous avez lu Renant comme moi mais il se
garde bien d'en parler les gens qui les
découvrent réussissent à développer
rapidement et facilement leur culture
générale parce que leur rapport au
savoir a changé et une fois qu'ils
appliquent les cinq secrets ils
comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ils savent
s'exprimer avec profondeur sur n'importe
quel sujet ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations et dans les
débats et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d'esprit critique ça
vous intéresse et bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets et je vous explique
comment les appliquer dès aujourd'hui
pour vous cultiver 10 fois plus
rapidement sans vous prendre la tête
pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites-le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier
secret qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire bonne
vidéo quand je sors avec mon chien je
rencontre souvent un voisin qui a lui
deux gros chiens ça fait des années
qu'on engage de petites discussions sur
le chemin et parfois il me dit qu'il
revient d'une balade de 2 heures dans la
forêt je comprends bien que les deux
grosses bêtes en ont besoin mais 2h de
promenade la vache il faut les faire
quand même B en fait 2hur de promenade
c'est rien pour Nietzsche sa routine
c'est 4h de balade en forêt en général
1h en fin de matinée et 3h dans
l'après-midi et il peut parfois passer
8h à marcher dans les bois c'est vrai
que la marche c'est bon pour la santé
que ça favorise l'inspiration mais 8h
pourquoi est-ce que Nietzsche marche
autant et bien pour lui ce n'est pas une
passion mais un remède et s'il marche
chaque jour c'est qu'il est tout le
temps malade il souffre de sévères
migrainees et de douleurs oculaires
jusqu'à l'incapacité de lire et d'écrire
depuis l'adolescence puis s ajoute les
troubles digestifs les spasmes les
vomissements les crises nerveuses et les
malaises et attention ce n'est pas de
temps en temps c'est une condition quasi
permanente lorsque Nietzsche est en
bonne santé c'est l'exception les
symptômes que j'ai Liss reviennent en
permanence il lui empoisonne la vie ça
en devient même lassant dans la
biographie ni checkouéoli ni cheouoli ni
cheou auit et cetera mais alors c'est
quoi sa maladie et bien c'est vraiment
pas clair on peut tout d'abord penser
que c'est héréditaire parce que son père
avait souffert de certains des symptômes
les crises nerveuses et les spasm
notamment mais certains symptômes
semblent plutôt liés à son mode de vie
en particulier Nietzsche travaille très
dur au point de multiplier les burnout
et cela dès l'enfance vers l'âge de 10
ans par exemple ses journées commenent à
5h du matin et il n'est n pas rare qu'il
fasse ses devoirs jusqu'à 11h du soir ça
fait seulement 5 6 he de sommeil
effectif pour une journée exténuante je
ne suis pas médecin mais je ne serai pas
étonné qu'un rythme aussi intense et des
conséquences à long terme autre
paramètre lié au mode de vie le climat
pour minimiser ces symptômes Nietzsche a
besoin de la bonne météo et de la bonne
température il dit carrément que les
nuages sont ses ennemis c'est la raison
pour laquelle il n'arrête pas de se
déplacer il vit entre bal sils Maria
Turin Nice et l'Allemagne enfin il reste
une dernière hypothèse la syphilis niet
tu l'aurais contracté lors de ses éud à
liiptic ce que confirmerait des visites
qu'il aurait effectué chez un médecin
spécialisé voilà pour les hypothèses
médicales maintenant il y a quelque
chose d'étonnant dans les symptômes de
nich parfois il est cloué au lit toute
une journée et il pète la forme le
lendemain au point de fatiguer les
personnes saines qui l'accompagnent en
forêt et si l'origine des symptômes
était psychologique et si Nietzsche
somatisait plusieurs personnes le
pensent dans son entourage et puis au
20e siècle les psychanalystes pencheront
pour cette interprétation c'est vrai que
niet se soumet depuis l'enfance à une
discipline extrême et puis il ne
touchera pas une femme de sa vie il
réprime l'expression de la nature en lui
lui même il l'a réprit même très
sévèrement j'ai un peu enquêté entre
guillemets sur internet et je pense
qu'ainsi parler zaratustra est
probablement le livre le plus vendu de
Nietzsche en tout cas c'est un des plus
connus et des plus vendus Nietzsche
avait placé beaucoup d'espoir dans ce
livre écrit à la fin de la trentaine
parce qu'il l'a composé avec une
profonde inspiration il dit même à ses
amis que c'est son meilleur livre qu'il
y a déversé son âme quelques années plus
tard au début de la quarantaine son
éditeur lui apprend qu'il n'a même pas
vendu 100 exemplaires d'insi par les
ustra même pas 100 exemplair l'imprimeur
ne s'était pas trompé en laissant le
manuscrit de côté Nietzsche ne
comprenait pas pourquoi l'impression
d'ainsi parler zaratustra était si
longue en fait l'imprimeur avait mis de
côté le manuscrit sans en informer
Nietzsche bien sûr pour satisfaire une
commande urgente de 500000 recueils de
cantique qui devait être livré à temps
pour PAC ces livres là ils allaient se
vendre bien sûr quand Nietzsche apprend
que le livre qu'il considère comme son
meilleur ne se vend pas du tout c'est la
déprime mais il a des indices qui
montrent qu'il n'est pas un auteur raté
à la même époque Nietzsche est à
Florence il est visite l'Observatoire
local et là devant lui un vieil
astronome aux cheveux et à la barbe
blanc comme neige se met à réciter
plusieurs aphorismes de humains trop
humin vous vous rendez compte vous êtes
à l'étranger et quelqu'un cite des
passages de votre livre devant vous ce
que montre cette anecdote c'est que
l'échec commercial n'est pas un échec
intellectuel bien sûr les livres de
Nietzsche ne se vendent pas au début de
la quarantaine il fait un bilan avec son
ancien éditeur des 13 livres qu'il a
écrit seul deux ont connu une seconde
édition dont les trois/arts des
exemplaires sont restés sur les bras de
l'éditeur concernant les 11 autres
livres celui qui a le moins mal marché a
vendu la moitié du stock imprimé et les
ventes sont médiocres pour tous les
autres et il y a pire plus Nietzsche
produit moins il vend avec moins de 100
ventes ainsi parleraratustra est un vrai
flop mais de l'autre côté Nietzsche a
des lecteurs capables de réciter des
passages de son œuvre ça ce ne sont pas
des lecteurs ce sont des fans des
adeptes lorsqu'il parle d'insi parler
zaratustra Nietzsche se compare parfois
à un prophète et bien c'est un peu ça
Nietzsche ne vit pas de sa plume mais il
a une base de fans d'adept qui par le
pouvoir du bouche à oreille vont
progressivement convertir la
masse voici une des plus célèbres photos
de Nietzsche elle a même été reprise
pour l'affiche d'un film la femme est
Lou Salomé une des plus célèbres
intellectuelles séductrices sinon la
plus célèbre intellectuelle séductrice
de l'Occident moderne et Nietzsche est
sa plus célèbre victime l'homme qui les
accompagne sur la photo Paul Reay est un
rentier fan de Nietzsche c'est lui qui a
présenté Lou Salomé à Nietzsche et si
Nietzsche vend très peu de livres il a
déjà le prestige intellectuel d'un
écrivain la jeune Lou Salomé une mande
de 21 ans qui a reçu une éducation ultra
privilégiée à Saint-Pétersbourg la jeune
Lou Salomé est flattée d'attirer
l'attention d'un philosophe accompli de
38 ans Nietzsche est agréablement
surpris par son intelligence et elle est
agréablement surprise par le caractère
de Nietzsche plus sympathique que prévu
Paul Ray déjà amoureux de la jeune
allemande et mis à l'écart ce qui le
rend jaloux Nietzsche s prend lui aussi
de loup Salomé mais c'est ce qui se
passe avec tous les intellectuels
qu'elle fréquente elle nouse des amitiés
amoureuses enfin amitié pour elle le
pasteur qui était son précepteur quand
elle était adolescente a voulu divorcer
pour l'épouser Paul Ray et Nietzsche
penseront eux aussi chacun de leur côté
au mariage mais l'ambiguïé de la
situation deux intellectuels
célibataires amis et pris en même temps
de la même jeune femme que l'un a
présenté à l'autre cette situation
spéciale leur fait imaginer une solution
spéciale très controversée pour l'époque
une trinité romantico-inttellectuelle
ils s'enthousiasme et chafaudent des
plans mais ils ne vivront jamais à trois
dans les fait les deux hommes se
disputent l'attention de Lou Salomé
chacun des deux essaie de l'attirer à
lui à son tour c'est la géniale
séductrice qui mène la danse d'ailleurs
le sens de la photo est cl Nietzsche et
poleré sont attelés à une charrette dont
loup tient les reenes alors que
Nietzsche placçait beaucoup d'espoir
dans cette trinité elle le rend en
réalité encore plus malheureux
constatant que les liens entre Lou
Salomé et Paul Ray se resserrent en son
absence il abandonne finalement
l'idée Nietzsche est au milieu de la
quarantaine il est à Turin et cette
ville lui va à ravir il dort comme un
bébé et quand il se regarde dans le
miroir il fait 10 ans de moins mais son
logeur lui n'a pas l'impression que
Nietzsche va si bien ses deux filles ont
vu le philosophe déchirer rageusement
des lettres au piano il fait parfois des
improvisations délirantes qui font mal
aux oreilles et puis un jour il écrit au
chancelier allemand autohon Bismark en
lui envoyant un exemplaire de son
nouveau livre et qui est homo il écrit à
Bismark qu'il est son ennemi et il signe
Friedrich Nietzsche l'antichrétien les
excentricités se multiplient il signe
des lettres comme s'il était la
réincarnation de Jésus-Christ il écrit
au roi d'Italie puis prétend qu'il va
lui rendre visite il joue au piano et
chante dans sa chambre pendant des
heures il commande des tonnes de
bouteilles de vin un jour le médecin qui
le suit est confronté à un spectacle
effroyable dans la chambre du philosophe
Nietzsche complètement nu qui bondit et
qui tournoie dans une danse dionysiaque
le diagnostic ne fait plus aucun doute
Nietzsche est fou sa mère le rapatrie
donc auprès d'elle il n'est plus capable
de vivre seul il a besoin d'une
assistance permanente sa mère le place
dans une institution puis le reprend
auprès d'elle bien sûr Nietzsche ne peut
plus écrire mais surtout il ne peut plus
défendre ses intérêts en tant
qu'auteur nous sommes en 1932 donc
nietzs est mort il y a plus de 30 ans
une pièce de théâtre sur Napoléon est
jouée au th Théâtre national de vaimar
et qui est-ce qui est dans le public
Hitler le chef du parti nazi à un moment
quelqu'un lui apprend qu'éliisabeth
Nietzsche la sœur du célèbre philosophe
est également présente dans le public
que fait Hitler il se rend dans la loge
d'Élisabeth et lui offre un énorme
bouquet de rose ils se sont déjà
rencontré à plusieurs reprises et se
connaissent personnellement cette
anecdote révèle que c'est la sœur de
Nietzsche qui est responsable de la
récupération de la philosophie
nietzscheenne par l'idéologie nazie mais
comment s'est-elle àoquiné avec les
nazis parce que les membres de la
famille de Nietzsche ne sont pas des
extrémistes et bien fait Elizabeth
Nietzsche devient nazie par amour à 39
ans elle épouse Bernhard firsturster un
agitateur d'extrême droite Nietzsche qui
est antiantisémite déteste son beaufère
on ne peut pas reprocher au mariés de ne
pas croire sincèrement en leurs idées
ils vont créer une colonie au Paraguay
pour refonder la race allemande ils ont
un train de vie de Prince mais la
réalité les rattrape à cause de dettes
et de conflits administratifs le projet
tourne au fiasco le mari d'Élizabeth
Nietzsche se suicide toujours attaché à
leur projet de colonie elle rentre en
Allemagne pour tenter de le sauver mais
elle s'occupe de son frère malade or
elle qui critiquait la philosophie des
premiers livres de Nietzsche elle est
devenue fan de lui depuis qu'elle a
constaté son appartenance à l'élite
culturelle allemande en partie grâce à
sa proximité passée avec Wagner il faut
le dire donc elle est persuadée de la
valeur des livres de son frère et il se
produit un phénomène étrange au moment
même où il devient fou les ventes de ces
livres commencent à décoller les
éditeurs veulent en profiter mais c'est
la sœur qui prend les choses en main
elle crée les archives Nietzsche pour
gérer l'œuvre de son frère devenu fou
elle dicte ses conditions aux éditeurs
puis elle met une grosse pression à sa
mère afin qu'elle renonce moyenne en
finance a ses droits sur l'œuvre de son
fils la sœur est le seul maître à bord
elle transforme alors l'œuvre de son
frère des livres qui plombaient les
comptes des éditeurs en un business
rentable elle prépare de nouvelles
éditions et lance des actions de
promotion de la pensée nietzschenne
notamment en l'assimilant au
nationalisme allemand elle écrit
elle-même une biographie de son frère
d'un côté elle est bien coupable de la
récupération de la pensée nietzsienne
par l'idéologie nazie elle adhéra
elle-même au parti nazi à 84 ans mais de
l'autre côté il faut lui reconnaître
deux choses d'abord elle a vraiment cru
en son frère elle a pris des risques
financiers pour devenir le patron d'une
entreprise dont on ne pouvait pas
prévoir qu'elle connaîtrait un tel
succès ensuite Elizabeth Nietzsche est
une femme forte c'est certainement sa
mésaventure au Paraguay qui l'a rendu
capable d'imposer fermement sa volonté
aux éditeurs et aux divers acteurs qui
voulaient tirer les marrons du feu c'est
grâce à sa volonté que la pensée de
Nietzsche a connu un tel succès mais
dans une version en partie
déformée si vous aimez l'esprit de cette
vidéo à savoir découvrir des choses
intéressantes en allant l'essentiel et
sans se prendre la tête alors vous
aimerez probablement mon programme
Culture Express c'est un programme
méthodique pour devenir facilement une
personne cultivé en seulement quelques
mois il couvre tous les domaines de la
culture générale vous maîtriserez les
connaissances essentielles sur
l'histoire de l'humanité sur l'histoire
de France en économie en science
politique en psychologie en Scien en
littérature en art en religion et en
philosophie vous ne serez plus jamais à
cours de choses à dire et vous gagnerez
la confiance nécessaire pour briller en
toutes circonstances vous pouvez en
savoir plus en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche iche en haut à droite ou bien
sur celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore en tapant directement
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran dans
la barre de recherche mais je pense que
la meilleure façon de vous donner une
idée du programme et d'écouter ce que
les membres ont à en dire Valentine qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à apprendre
ce travail est vraiment formidable et
passionnant Maxence m'écrit directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme la formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui est une mémoire essentiellement
auditive le choix des thèmes et des
chapitres est pertinent et je trouve que
tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite à la fois précis mais sans
fioriture vincent lui fait carrément ma
pub j'ai d'ailleurs recommandé votre
formation à ma sœur qui travaille comme
diplomate la semaine dernière elle a
déjà eu l'occasion de mettre à profit
dans ces discussions les connaissances
que vous avez diffusé vous verrez
d'autres témoignages comme ceci dans
dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme et si vous vous inscrivez
vous bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat
une fois que vous aurez terminé le
programme je vous rembourserai
intégralement si vous estimez que vous
n'avez pas acquis une solide culture
générale si vous voulez en savoir plus
cliquez sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite ou bien sur celui qui est
dans la description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tiré partie de
ce programme et je serai ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour vous dans tous les cas
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu je suis
romain et vous vous étiez sur l'idé de
culture générale rappelez-vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la
[Musique]
pensée